I'm joined on the program today by
William Gardner who's a former Olympian
and author of the Great Divide why
liberals and conservatives will never
ever agree which may well be true
William first set up for us why you
chose to write a book on this topic well
I got tired of going to social
gatherings or to a dinner party and
whenever a interesting topic was raised
there was either silence or outrage and
I thought something's wrong in the West
certainly in our country Canada and I
think you probably have the same
experience down there when I was a young
man if you're about say 20 years old and
such a gathering you're expected to have
opinions and you would be chastised
lehre stupid opinions or poorly argued
but I can't remember anyone ever
expressing outrage of the kind of we
hear so often today and to me this
indicated a world that was kind of going
silent on the major issues a place
philosophically morally politically you
know people segregating off into
different attitude groups not really
discussing things with each other and
frightened of debate and frightened to
get called out on their own arguments so
I thought someone's got to write a book
that gets at the sub structure here so
if you'll permit me I'll just say what
the purpose was I I imagined a man
standing out on the street on a
beautiful day beautiful buildings all
around him and suddenly there's a huge
gasp in the street and the buildings
start to shake and there's rubble and
bricks falling all over the place and
the first thing he says is oh my Gus
it's an earthquake but of course it's
not an earthquake the earthquake is
waiting on below the ground in the
geological forces that are crashing and
grinding away and he can't see those
what he sees of the rubble or the
consequences of the earthquake so I
thought we needed a book which gets that
the ideological forces that are grinding
away beneath the political rubble at the
surface you know in our in our
democracies so a seismologist for
example can see the geological forces
but ordinary people can't and in this
book I try to reveal the ideological
forces it's not about party politics or
anything like that it's about it's about
political and moral philosophy and the
arguments people on the liberal and
conservative side tend to have over
these issues
okay so let's dig into some of what you
said there you mentioned sort of earlier
on in your your overview of the book
that you have noticed some of the
outrage that some now have when it comes
to political ideology opinions positions
on policy etc and you said that that
that is a negative thing is it possible
though that one might be outraged more
now than previously because the
positions being taken by some on
political issues are more outrageous I
mean is that a possibility that you're
open to markets a possibility but I
think of that sort of comment with all
due respect is a kind of popular conceit
and we tend to think that you know
nothing has been as outrageous as the
things we're experiencing today I think
the Romans were out just as outraged as
we get at all sorts of things in their
time so it's a bit of a concede to think
that something's worse or better today
than it was in the past but I can't tell
you how many public speeches I'd given
where somebody will stand up after the
speech and say mr. dare I'm outraged by
what you've been saying and I look them
right in the eye and I say well you
couldn't be more outraged than I am now
what's your point yeah no I understand
that but I guess my question is you've
indicated that the presence of outrage
is indicative of either ignorance or
lack of openness to other ideas or
whatever the case may be but outrage is
not an invalid human emotion outrage is
not an invalid reaction to what one
might be doing and I'm looking at the
book and in hearing you talk it concerns
me a little bit that we're dismissing
outrage out of hand in a sense well as I
said I think that's an outrage can be a
cover-up in a way of escaping the depth
and the logic of someone else's argument
yeah it can be saying you know I think
saying that out that that's a conceded
opinion that's not really an argument is
it
I didn't say conceded NSN a conceit it's
a little different but leave that behind
for the moment I'm simply saying then I
think people go to a motive which some
philosophers call and psychologists call
emotivism as a kind of escape from
challenge and I think that's what we're
seeing all around us we're seeing either
silence in other words we just don't
really certain topics at the dinner
table or at a social gathering yes we
are in fact frightened oh no each and
people are using a motion to scare you
well I think I you know the point of
agreement we could probably have in the
interest of finding common ground and
then figuring out where our differences
are is I do think that a response such
as I'm offended by what you're saying
full-stop that is also not an argument
and not productive and I think you'd
probably agree with me there when we
talk about particular issues are there
any particular issues and you write
about a lot of them in the book that you
believe are particularly intractable in
modern society or are the more likely
issues to get us at an impasse when
there are political disagreements well
look I think it's important for your
listeners to understand what the Great
Divide is about it's really about
self-discovery it's helping readers to
articulate their ideas instead of their
emotions or their outrage so at the end
of each chapter and I have to say in the
interest of flagrant self-promotion that
this is the first book that I have ever
read or seen and I've seen an awful lot
of them in my time in which you get an
actual clear delineation of the two
sides in a kind of table form at the end
of each chapter you've probably seen
those is about 14y in the book and I
think the subtitle of the book which is
why liberals and conservatives will
never ever agree should have been
instead something like this
find out how liberal or conservative you
really are and that we actually get to
leaders all the time they go to the
tables and they say oh my goodness you
know I didn't realize I was as liberal
as I am or that I'm so conservative and
your your tables help me to clarify the
kind of person that I really am in terms
of my political moral philosophy so to
me that was a huge contribution and I
incur
your listeners should to go get them oh
yeah I mean well you know I saw those
tables and the table I you know I can't
speak to whether the format of cabling
some of these ideas is is a unique one
or one that that's been tried before but
the concern I had and I know that you
will address this in a very specific way
is that in the book you do sort of set
yourself up as an arbiter between left
and right or at least someone who can
tell us this is what it would mean to be
conservative on this issue and what it
would mean to be liberal but you do have
skin in the game right I mean I've been
reviewing your recent tweets on your
Twitter account over the last couple of
months and you you have you have a
significant bias on a lot of these
issues and I'm wondering if you were
concerned in setting up these tables and
parameters if if you what caution what
care you took to try to prevent your
personal biases from impacting your
views on in the book well David I
encourage you to read of the
introduction to the book where I do
discuss this and I say that I was I
began as a young kind of socialist
leftist like a lot of people you know
the old saying if you're not a socialist
by the time you're 20 you haven't got a
heart if you're still a socialist for
the time you're 40 you don't have any
brains yeah I think it's a terrible
statement I think it's totally bogus but
I have heard it we can we can debate
that another time so anyway the winds
the winds of experience and my reading
and thinking blew me over to the right
side of the divide but in the
introduction I make it clear that I'm
trying to illustrate both sides of the
equation here as fairly as I can and I
think a lot of people who read the book
of said to me you know you did a pretty
good job of it however to take your
point no one can do a perfect job I say
in the introduction it's like playing
chess against yourself someone has to
win the game and you know that when
you're playing if you've ever played
chess against yourself how that flips
back and forth should they make this
move or not so it was difficult and I
don't hide the fact from anybody that
I'm a what I call a true conservative
thinker in fact people asked me what's
it been like writing and thinking about
these kinds of things the last 35 years
of your life and I say you know what I
feel like I've been a man standing on
the
rock in the middle of a leftward
drifting sea and in the distance I can
see ships through the fog and they're
drifting to the left and I your voices
you know what the same they're saying
look look there's a man out there
drifting to the right that's the
situation in Canada certainly when I
started a lot of things that I wrote
about I was chastised for by the left
called me extremists k marriage there's
never going to be such a thing you're
such an extreme is saying something like
that I said now you wait and see
so here it is and I just feel like I
said I haven't changed my position I'm a
kind of Burkean in social and moral
philosophy on the libertarian an
economic philosophy and so on and I'm
arguing pretty much the same positions I
began with 35 years ago all right well
let's pause exactly on that point with
William Gardner who is the author of the
Great Divide why liberals and
conservatives will never ever agree and
tomorrow we will pick up this
conversation talking more specifically
about some of the issues that William
just mentioned and also discusses in the
book we're continuing our conversation
with William Gardner who's a former
Olympian and also author of the book the
Great Divide why liberals and
conservatives will never ever agree
let's talk about some political issues
you mentioned at the end of part one of
our interview gay marriage I noticed
that on your website you have a
declaration of marriage talk to us a
little bit about that you talk about
marriage as being defined as one man and
one woman etc you as you mentioned have
believed for some time that there would
ultimately be legal gay marriage in
Canada and presumably in some other
countries as well what's your view on
gay marriage is it something that you're
behind or you're against well first of
all let me say that philosophically
speaking I don't think the state should
have any interest in marriage whatsoever
it's a private affair between citizens
except for one thing which happens to be
so important it trumps everything else
and that is that heterosexual marriage
provides the state with citizens so that
it continued to exist and that's why the
only reason I can think of why the state
should be involved in marriage at all
they shouldn't be involved because
people
of each other that has nothing to do
with it because people fall out of love
lots of people who say I have a right to
marry because I love so-and-so what do
they say later when they divorce when
they say I hate them you know and so
love has nothing to do with it and I've
always felt that in the West and I argue
this in some of my writings that
marriage traditionally speaking is like
a four-legged chair we've always said
number gender age and incest he's saying
you can only marry one person at a time
we don't want polygamy most people still
agree with that it should be somewhat of
the opposite sex because two men and two
women cannot procreate with each other
okay but let's just want to slow it down
it's just a hair because there's a lot
here I don't want it I don't want to
skip over something that might be might
be relevant you made an interesting
point which is the interest of the state
in heterosexual marriage over homosexual
marriage would be that because
heterosexual couples are able to
procreate that creates more people which
presumably allows for hold a hold on a
second if I'm if I'm stating it
incorrectly I'll allow you to correct it
but my understanding would be the state
would prefer heterosexual marriages
because they lead to more people through
procreation which does what increases
the taxpaying population or provides
people for maybe being in a military
what would be good about that for the
state I just explained it to you in
Canada for example we are not replacing
ourselves naturally we're doing it
through immigration we are dying people
the replacement rate in every society is
2.1 children per woman Canada has been
procreating at the rate of
one-point-five for 35 years so we've had
to rely on dislocating immigration I say
dislocating because a lot of the
immigrants that we bring in really could
care less about our core values as they
have traditionally been upheld in this
country so okay creates all sorts of
other problems of it's another program
but what I was getting at because I
think you mangled my point a bit how did
is it yes is that two homosexuals cannot
procreate with each other so all I'm
saying is that in in Canada when they
legalized gay marriage they
ever went to the fine point here they
talked about Conger Galilee as being the
basis of marriage whether or not you
were homeless actual reversal content
but you can't join two penises and you
can't join two vaginas no conjugal he
was it was a false term to use in the
Supreme Court of Canada okay oh and well
I just I want to try not to get too far
ahead of ourselves you certainly seem to
understand the sort of fidget physiology
of human sexuality that part I don't
think anybody could could deny you but
my question is the following
even if someone is in a gay relationship
and they are or aren't allowed to get
married that doesn't change whether they
can procreate right so I guess what I'm
curious about is if the interest of the
state is encouraging procreation gay
people are not going to procreate in the
way that you describe whether they're
married or not and nobody is going to be
sort of convinced to be in a
heterosexual relationship merely because
they can't get married are they so out
what I'm not I'm understanding the
physiology of what you're saying what
I'm not understanding is how you're
actually changing the amount of kids
people will have by allowing versus not
allowing gay marriage first of all
before your listeners get the wrong idea
I want to say that this is one in
fourteen topics in my book no I agree
but but since you're entertaining things
that don't make sense to me I want to
explore them I'm happy to explore them I
just don't want to reduce to get the
wrong idea but or it's not about that's
one of the topics sure and and then and
in that chapter I what's one of your
American reviewers I can't remember who
down there said they were ferocious
arguments what he meant was even if you
don't like the arguments deal with them
buddy because these are darn good
arguments which we haven't seen before
well but hold on a second William hold
on a second just saying that your
argument is good in response to my
specific question is not really an
argument my specific question is if
you're arguing that the one reason you
have for opposing state sanctioned gay
marriage is the state has an interest in
furthering heterosexual procreation my
specific question was heterosexual
couples can procreate
whether they're in or outside of a
marriage and gay couples while they can
adopt and now increasingly we their
their other medical options available in
the way you're talking about a gay
couple is not going to procreate whether
or not they are able to get married so
how is that argument a strong one that
you made well you cut me off before I
finished what I was telling you about
number gender age and incest because we
also say you can't marry someone below a
certain age and you shouldn't marry a
close relative
that's the four-legged chair I was
talking about now I'm getting to your
policy a question because what I saw
when I wrote the Declaration on marriage
which your listeners can find on my
website was that one leg of the chair
has been taken off both in America and
Canada and almost all the other Western
democracies but but not all of them and
so I was concerned about what does this
mean what is what is the policy
supporting marriage for anyway well
policy is like a shotgun it's not like a
rifle you know you you put the policy
out and you hope to attract millions of
people to the policy of marrying some of
the opposite sex so that you can have
more citizens we know that if you put a
lot of boys and girls together you're
going to have a lot of babies that's the
state's interest and they have to me
they should not be bonusing or
privileges
other forms of relationship you know I'm
enough of a libertarian to say if you
want to live with whoever you want go
ahead it's not really my business but
William how is how is allowing gay
marriage how is allowing gay marriage
bonusing some other alternative isn't it
just allowing the exact same thing that
a heterosexual couple is allowed it's
not a bonus it's it's equality I'm
saying why should that's why I said the
state has no business and marriage
except for the prospect of producing
more citizens and gay people cannot
produce citizens with each other
therefore they shouldn't be bonused so
to speak or rewarded by the state for
getting married let them get married
similarly similarly if they want to go
to the Church of their jelly's with
state marriages a civil marriage isn't
it but I don't understand the
distinction but I don't think I don't
think governments should be I mean
there's hundreds of laws that are tied
up with this whole argument about
bonusing thorough sections for getting
married like I don't think we should be
giving
medals for for courage and bravery in
battle to non soldiers I don't think we
should be giving senior citizens
benefits to an adolescent's and I don't
think we should get marital benefits to
anybody except people who marry someone
of the opposite sex look it's an
argument yeah you have to do your
argument I'm dealing with it no I think
you you don't like how I'm dealing with
it but I'm certainly dealing with it in
a pretty direct way let's just because I
know this is one of many issues that
you've talked about let's at least dip
into one other area that you've you've
spoken and written about that I find
very interesting not long ago the
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
sent out a tweet about embracing
differences and diversity and you
responded that nations have a core
culture can you talk about that a little
bit yeah I think I think for example the
core culture in Canada and Americans
share a lot of this has been a liberal
democracy it's been a focus on
individual independence and
self-reliance in Canada's case with the
exception of the French minority here
which which managed to negotiate
adequate rice in Canada's of original
constitution in 1867 the Christian the
judeo-christian format of our of our
moral culture all these things are what
I call a deep culture and I think people
who promote multiculturalism and I have
dear friends who do this with whom I'm
arguing all the time yeah I say look you
have to distinguish between skin-deep
culture and deep culture skin deep
cultures you know Japanese food Italian
cars French you know French movies or
whatever it is you like we all like that
kind of stuff and we all want a certain
amount of amount of it to make life
interesting
okay deep felt deep cultures another
matter and I've always felt that when it
comes to things like immigration we
should be trying to attract people who
at least have a high respect for the
deep culture or the core culture of the
country which is undeniable it's what I
sold you went to war and fought for you
know over and over again and yours too
I thought our soldiers what went to war
for other things but that let's not
rehash American history now I guess my
specific question on this idea of core
culture and
since immigration is part of it and what
skin deep or deep culture is there a
racial component to what core cultural
aspects are compatible well my dad went
to Europe to fight National Socialism
Nazism and you would be shocked to know
how many of the things that Hitler was
promoting as National Socialism that you
down there and we up here are doing
today okay but that was my question
William that's okay that was my answer
okay let me try once more is race a
factor in evaluating who can be a
successful part of what you call the
core culture of Canada or the u.s. no it
doesn't have to be at all it doesn't
happen to me but effectively is it do
you believe of Babycham it may be that
people of certain races are coming from
certain cultural origins and and don't
share ours and don't want to share them
if that becomes an issue it's an issue
it's not my issue and what should the
policy be around immigration in other
words how do you create an immigration
policy around that idea well let me give
you an example I say the Canada for
example and America the same has always
been multi-ethnic but it's never before
been multicultural and this whole
business of multiculturalism was brought
about in Canada because of the threat of
separation by the people of Quebec
you know the separatist kept one-party
Catholic wall party was trying to
separate from Canada and the Canadian
government said you know we got a dilute
all this we're going to dilute the
French demands and the French influence
in Canada and we can do that with a
multicultural policy will say that
diversity is beautiful etcetera etc and
there's no question as I said from the
skin V Culture point of view it is
beautiful well yeah like you like
Chinese food but that's not the same as
wanting a particular immigration policy
no it's not that it's not the same as
having for example a a board of
governors on your school or councilors
that your local municipality who decide
to put a Taoist or Chinese temple in a
vacant piece of land instead of saying a
Christian Church which had always been
there they're tearing
down and they're putting up a mosque
well hold on wait but hold on a second
William you first met putting a Taoists
temple where there's nothing but then
you said ripping down the Christian
Church that was already there though
that's those are two very different
situations aren't they
yeah but either one I think would be a
kind of diminution of the core culture
of the country what so it's religious so
although race may be a factor you're
saying that really religion is where the
incompatibilities may be well I think
that what I call deep culture is made up
of ethnicity religion language
literature music I mean if the whole the
whole stick mm-hm and I think the
multicultural policy is sweet-sounding
as it is is a contradiction in terms
there's no such thing as a multi culture
and I'm much more interested in
university than diversity although we
all know that a certain amount of
diversity is interesting in our society
everybody likes that Wow but you know if
you see an attack on the core aspects of
your whole society and the things which
made your society great in the first
place are being weakened or taken down
by some kind of threat internally then I
think you out you ought to be fighting
back and defending the things that that
you and the rest of the citizens have
always valued and and in my correct in
that your example of the Taoists temple
would be such an attack on the core
culture of society well take the second
example better if you have a palace
temple and lots of your Christian
churches around and your Society has
been rooted in judeo-christian
civilization for 2,000 years then that's
okay but if knife in fact all your
Christian churches institutions
organizations charities and universities
what's got to start through the
Christian dispensation if they're all
being taken down replaced removed I
think you have a concern and is that
happening anywhere right now that you're
worried about well I get reports that
it's happening a lot in England a lot in
Europe a lot of churches are being
converted into mosques for example
reporte I think
and so I say well if that's the truth
it's a concern you know and all right I
think the West is struggling with this
David I really do because it's the first
time we've really seen a threat to
Western civilization from the inside
when he began when I was a Stanford
I am the 60s yeah there were the fact of
course they're called Western Civ
everybody was required to take it now
it's gone it's been gone for 30 years
well that will be a topic for another
conversation I think it's it's been
endlessly fascinating hearing about
William Gardner's political philosophy
we've been sort of talking about some of
the ideas in his book the Great Divide
why liberals and conservatives will
never ever agree William it's been very
interesting speaking with you I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this you too let's do it again you take
care